brittany griner pleads guilty in russian
court
the wnba star was arrested at a moscow
airport in february with russian
officials claiming she had cannabis oil
in her luggage
i would like to
plead guilty on the charges had no
intention on breaking any russian law if
ultimately convicted on drug possession
and smuggling charges brittany could
face 10 years in a russian prison
following her plea brittany's trial is
expected to resume on july 14th
so with the plea in place her defense
team and u.s officials edged closer
toward a court verdict as well as
attempts to secure brittany's release we
are not going to ever be quiet until
she's home safely the president
responded to a letter griner wrote him
from prison pleading for action he
called griner's wife wednesday telling
her he is working to secure brittany's
release as soon as possible following
this latest development britney's coach
vanessa nygaard gave a passionate plea
in wanting brittany home safe
i'm a basketball coach i know about
picking roles i don't know a lot about
russian law hopefully this is a step in
the right direction and we look to see
the biden administration and all of our
government officials continue to do
everything they can to help bring
brittany home as fast as possible also
on thursday brittany gets support from
megan repino at the white house where
the soccer star was accepting the
presidential medal of freedom on megan's
suit her lapel sports the initials bg
megan shared this pick to her instagram
story adding quote the most important
part of today
you